That's an interesting way of putting it, Seamus.
No doubt. I do interesting very well.
It's trusting I don't do so well.
Oh, please.
Hi, this is Seamus. He's our new partner.
I ain't no such thing.
Prospective new partner, if he likes us.
Liking ain't the problem. Trusting is, as I said.
Keep your voices down. I don't want my boss hearing.
This is a sideline.
Of course. Look at us. Honest as the day is long.
Exactly.
I tell you what. Let us prove ourselves.
Prove ourselves? To this clown? What you talking about?
Good day, Hosea. Good luck with your business dealings.
Listen, he's rough and ready and quick with his tongue,
but I swear you can trust him and trust me.
I'm an old man.
You're not old, Seamus.
I'm old enough. And you know why I ain't dead?
You don't trust idiots.
Exactly.
We're not idiots. Let us prove it to you.
Okay. I'll tell you what.
Arthur!
Old Bob Crawford and his boys just bought a beautiful stolen stagecoach from Upstate.
It's in their barn.
Now you go get that.
And then we can work together.
Who's old Bob Crawford?
An acquaintance of mine.
So you want us to take out your competition?
Well, he's not just an acquaintance, but a cousin.
By marriage.
I also want to see if you've got a chance to get a job.
I'm sure your boy's got what it takes.
You survived that.
Where is he?
He's in a farmhouse just northwest of here called Carmody Dell.
It's just up the train tracks as you're heading up towards Fort Wallace.
There's also some money in that house, but that's your business, not mine.
But don't kill nobody.
Folks know we ain't intimate no more, and they'll know it was me.
But you're fine with us robbing your cousin?
By marriage.
And yes, I'd love it.
You heard the man. Let's go rob his cousin.
By marriage.
I'm sure he'll be happy.
Really?
Really.
I'm sure he'll be happy.
Lead the way. He said the place is just northwest of here.
Look where you're going.
Me?
The other one who's been out gallivanting around here.
That's what you call it.
Clearly you've recovered from your bear encounter.
Careful.
I know.
Hup.
Ugh.
Oh, you little eater.
You pressed for my dinner?
You'll soon disappear into Elysee's Nutrigalivas till the sun comes up.
Don't mess with Quigley's
the whole month you idiot.
From North Carolina he said.
If the two of us can't steal the stagecoach from Seamus' old crooked cousin by marriage,
we should hang up our hats now.
Yaaah!
So what's the story with that Emerald Ranch?
You find out anything else?
A little.
Owner's a nasty type, by all accounts.
Seamus is sure scared of him.
That's not saying much.
Something strange about the place.
There used to be a saloon there, general store.
Now it's all closed up, but they seem to have money.
Hey, let's keep it down now. We must be close.
That must be the place up ahead.
We should go on foot from here.
Let's see what we're dealing with. Come on.
Let's go!
Come on, let's go!
There's the house. I see the barn in the back. Stagecoach has to be in there.
Okay, let's take a quick look at the place.
Yaaah!
Anyone around?
Yes.
Okay.
I reckon we can do it now.
I'll head over, distract them by putting on a little show.
You sneak into the house, find what you can, then get the stagecoach.
Or wait until nightfall.
Or sneak in, then I'll get the coach.
You can try the house. What do you think?
Let's wait.
Okay, let's go.
Sure.
You go into the house. I'll go find this wagon.
Maybe take a peek through the windows before you go in.
Make sure it's all quiet.
You don't want to let the bookies get to you.
I'm sure I'll watch me.
Knew you had it.
bai
Sarah?
Look...
The rest are dead...
I'll send해서
Don'tond
You're Teacher.
fetters.
Don'ton Gotcha.
I'm sorry.
Nice work, Jose.
It was mostly Arthur. Like I said, coarse, but competent.
Here.
Thank you.
If you find any other coaches that need selling, I'll see what I can offer you for them.
But discreet, you know.
Of course. Goodbye, gentlemen.
I'm heading back to camp, I think. You coming?
Nah, I'll catch up with you later.
Okay. Stay out of trouble.
Okay.
All right.